INTERVIEWER:
Hi.
Can you tell us your name and
what course you teach?
PROF.
WAITZ: My name is Ian Waitz and
I teach Unified Engineering.
INTERVIEWER:
Can you tell us a bit about the
class?
PROF.
WAITZ: It is a large class that
is put together by several
different faculty members.
We have taught it this way for
about 25 or 30 years.
INTERVIEWER:
In which department?
PROF.
WAITZ: In Aeronautics and
Astronautics.
And it provides education in
several of the important
disciplines for Aerospace
Engineering or Aeronautics and
Astronautics;
structures, fluids,
propulsion, thermodynamics,
computers and programming,
signals and systems and systems
engineering.
And those are all taught in an
integrated way over a year long
period.
And it is two semesters with
two subjects per semester,
so it is the equivalent of four
subjects put together in one.
INTERVIEWER:
And how many students take this
and what year are they?
PROF.
WAITZ: It is the entry-level
subject, or set of subjects for
our department,
so all students who come into
our department take it.
And they all take it as
sophomores primarily.
And this year we have about 75
students in it.
INTERVIEWER:
And I understand there has been
a bit of a team approach to
teaching the class.
Can you describe how that was
worked out?
PROF.
WAITZ: Yes.
It has evolved over time but we
are each allotted a certain
number of lectures of the total
number of lectures.
And for each lecture there is a
homework that goes with that.
And those lectures are all
interwoven with one another in a
certain order that makes some
sense in terms of the delivery
of the material.
And it is team taught.
But you show up and teach your
lectures and you tend to work
with the other people to
understand what their teaching
at the same time that you are
teaching.
You try and develop common
problems, common homework
problems that stress more than
one discipline so that you can
look at some of the
inner-relationships and
trade-offs between the different
disciplines.
INTERVIEWER:
OK.
So what do students do in
class?
Is it primarily lecture or do
they work in groups on projects?
PROF.
WAITZ: The classes are
lecture-based but we have
adopted a lot of active learning
strategies.
And we have done that for the
last several years.
There are two techniques that
we use predominantly.
One we call the Personal
Response System,
PRS.
It is a commercially available
product.
It is a small television
clicker.
I have got one here some place.
So this is the television
clicker.
And typically in a lecture
there will be one or two
questions that are asked,
sometimes three or four,
and the students respond to
these with these television
clickers.
And in real-time in the class
we get the responses back.
And we can look at graphs of
their responses.
So it is a short five or ten
minute lecture with a question.
Another short five or ten
minute lecture,
another question.
And that allows you in
real-time to understand what
they are having difficulty with
and what things they have made
progress on understanding and
adjust your lecture as you go.
That is the primary in-class
technique for engaging the
students.
We don't grade them on whether
or not they get the right
response.
We just grade them on whether
or not they have hit the button.
So it is part of the subject
grade.
There is an attendance score
which is calculated by how many
times they have pressed the
button out of the total number
of questions that are asked.
And, as I said,
it is two or three per lecture.
The second thing that we do for
each lecture is at the end we
finish the lectures a few
minutes early and we ask the
students to fill out the
muddiest part of the lecture
cards, so here are some from
lecture today,
where we ask them to take two
or three minutes and reflect on
the items that were discussed in
lecture and which part was the
least clear.
So the muddiest part of the
lecture.
And these are terrific.
With these you can find out,
in an anonymous way,
in the student's own words
which things they found to work
and which things that they found
to be difficult.
And often you find that items
that are tripping them up are
the symbols that you used or
that they have some lack of
understanding or some deficiency
in remember some prerequisite
subject material that you had
presumed that they had.
And getting this after each
lecture then you can take action
on these either by modifying
your next lecture or what I do
is respond to them all on the
subject webpage.
So I just write short answers
for each of the questions and
the students can go and look at
that.
So those are the two techniques
that we use within the lectures
for better feedback and for
active learning.
There is also a series of
laboratory exercises and systems
problems, but I presume you will
get an interview with Charles
Coleman or something to talk
about that aspect of the course.
INTERVIEWER:
But you had said that there are
laboratory assignments as well,
and there are other special
elements.
There are field trips and
things for this class.
PROF.
WAITZ: Yes, there are a variety
of special elements for Unified
as a whole.
For the lecture that I teach,
one of the things that I do is
wheel in an engine and teach in
front of the engine.
And it is a real engine.
It is a CFM56 which powers
Boeing 737 airplanes.
And when you're talking about
propulsion, having a couple
millions dollars worth of
hardware there to point to and
shake and have the students ask
questions about is very,
very helpful.
So there are elements like
that.
There are a lot of in-class
small demonstrations that each
of us do where we ask people to
work problems where they
estimate things or small
in-class experiments.
All of those are in the context
of these concept questions,
or many of them are where we
ask the students to observe an
experiment, to think about it
and to respond to some question
all intended to demonstrate
physical principles or to get
them to think about concepts in
the class.
INTERVIEWER:
OK.
Well, we want to thank you very
much for making your materials
available through MIT
OpenCourseWare.
Is there anything else you can
think of that you would like
someone to know about how
Unified is taught or anything
else that might not be obvious
from just viewing the course
materials online?
PROF.
WAITZ: No.
I would just say that it is
very important to us in
developing and delivering the
course materials that it be
viewed by the students in an
integrated way as a package so
that none of the sets of
materials were developed as
independent pieces on
thermodynamics or fluids but
they were developed within the
context of it being an
integrated course.
And we think that is very
important for educating students
in aeronautics and astronautics
that they do have this
integrated system level view of
how the pieces fit together.
And we prefer to start that
early by doing it all at once
early in their careers and then
have them take disciplinary
specialties later on rather than
vice versa.
So that is the only thing that
I would point out about it,
that it really has been
developed to be an integrative
learning environment.
INTERVIEWER:
OK.
Well, thank you very much for
your time.
PROF.
WAITZ: Pleasure.